>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Lee Ann Potter: If you search
David Baldacci, like I did,
in the Library of Congress's
online catalog, you get 89 results.
Not only are his novels in
the library's collections,
but movies inspired by his novels
are also included as well as books
that he contributed to
and versions of his books
in languages other than English.
Anybody want to guess how many
different languages his books have
been translated into?
>> Forty-five.
>> Lee Ann Potter:
Hey, who said that?
Forty-five is right, that's awesome.
Are you related?
[laughter].
So he's a prolific writer, but David
is also a devoted philanthropist
and his greatest efforts
are dedicated
to his family's Wish
You Well Foundation.
Established by David
and his wife Michelle,
the Wish You Well Foundation
supports family
and adult literacy
in the United States.
Today, David is here to talk with
us about "The Width of the World,"
book three in his instant
best-selling Vega Jane series.
Please join me in welcoming
best-selling author, David Baldacci.
[ Applause ]
>> David Baldacci: Hey, everybody.
Are we having a great
time at the festival?
>> Yeah. [applause].
>> David Baldacci: I know.
Somebody asked me, what's the
great thing about book festivals?
And I said the great thing
about book festivals is
that it brings people together who
may not have read a book for a while
or people who love books
and read lots of them
and everybody in between.
The worst thing about
book festivals --
they're too rare, there aren't
enough of them, I don't think.
And I always talk about this
and make this point when I come
to a book festival, if you have
a book festival in your town,
never take it for granted.
Because once you start taking
it for granted, it will go away
and you won't have it anymore
because people won't come
and it'll just sort of slide away.
I've seen it happen
to other festivals.
This is the National Book
Festival, we have got this.
We're going to come every year and
it's going to get bigger and better.
[applause].
I've written lots of books,
mostly adult stuff, thrillers,
that my own kids couldn't read
until they were a little bit older.
I remember the first time
my daughter, who's now grown
and moved on, read one of my books.
Her mom said it was okay
to read one of my thrillers
and it was Split Second in
the King and Maxwell Series,
sort of a pretty intense book
and my wife and I came home
from dinner one night and every
light in the house was on.
[laughter].
Her bedroom door was locked.
I think she had the bureau
shoved against the door.
We have two big dogs.
Both of them were in bed with
her -- once we get the door open.
And she told her mom later,
she goes, Mom, I get it.
I understand why Dad's so popular.
He's really good but
he's also like a freak.
[laughter].
When she was in kindergarten,
you know, you'd have Parents Come
to School Day and, you know, what
do your mom and dad do for a living?
My daughter never invited me.
And I asked her that, you
know, she got older and I said,
why didn't you invite me?
And she goes, well, what
are you going to do, Dad?
Come in and like write in a book?
You know? Sign your name?
How exciting is that?
We've got cops, we've
got firemen, you know?
I didn't want to be
embarrassed, I'm sorry.
I am a writer today because
I was a reader as a kid.
I was a library rat, you know?
Instead of a gym rat,
I was a library rat.
And I would go to my school library,
I would go to the county
public library in Richmond,
Virginia every weekend
with my brother and sister.
And I had secret deals
with the librarians.
They'd let me check out more
books than they were supposed
to let me check out because I
knew I would read all of them
and come back for more
the next week.
And I saw the world
through books, you know?
I never really left Richmond as a
kid, didn't have the opportunity,
but I saw a much broader spectrum
of life -- an existence perspective,
opinion, ideas and
wisdom and knowledge
from the books that I would open.
I went into the author's room, where
there's sort of a break room for all
of the authors here today, and
it was such a wonderful thing
because there were so many
young authors in there.
I mean, that's the new
voices of the future,
that's the fresh blood
of an industry.
They're going to write books that,
today, do not exist and won't exist
until they sit down and
create them and that's
such a wonderful, wonderful thing.
I've been doing this
a long time now.
Twenty years ago, I was
the new kid on the block.
I think that's a band -- or used
to be anyway -- showing my age.
But it really all began for me as
a writer because I was a reader.
Now, I was one of those kids growing
up who never shut up, you know?
That's why I went on later
to become a trial lawyer --
very similar skill
set there, you know --
never shutting up,
being a trial lawyer.
So and I would always tell
these tall tales, you know,
usually to get myself out
of trouble with parents,
assorted school officials,
people like that.
And one day my mom came to me and
she said, I bought you this journal.
I went to the bookstore,
I bought you this journal,
it's a blank page journal.
Why don't you write down some
of the stuff you've been
talking about all these years?
And I said, okay.
So I put my pen to paper and
it was like this epiphany,
it was like this ah-ha moment.
Oh my gosh, I can take what's
up here and I can put it
down on this and, eventually,
other people can read it,
just like the books that I love
to read, that I'm enthralled by.
I can have that same sort
of effect over other people.
And from that moment on -- I
was eight or nine years old --
I really never looked
back from that.
I just kept writing.
And years later, I went back to
my mom and I said, my God, Mom.
Thank you.
What a gift you gave me that day.
And my mom, you know, looked
at me and said, honey,
I'm so glad it's worked out
for you but, quite frankly,
I just wanted to shut you up.
[laughter].
You know, I'm your mom, I love you.
I will always love you.
But even moms need a little
peace and quiet, you know?
So that journal did it for her.
Now when I tour around, I get a lot
of questions from people, usually,
you know, the question I
get more than any other is,
what is it like to be this number
one worldwide best-selling novelist?
You know, I know the way they ask
the question they want some sort of,
you know, Entertainment Weekly
kind of answer, you know?
Yes, I have a life just
like the Kardashians do.
My life is nothing
like the Kardashians.
You know, I go to these
cool events sometimes.
I come home and I start
telling my wife about them
and she's like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's trash night, get on it.
[laughter].
People will always ask me, you know,
in every book you've ever written,
there are strong, independent
women, why is that?
Well, I was raised by one, I'm
married to one, and we raised one
and that's all I've ever
known in my whole life.
I don't write about damsels
in distress for one reason --
I've never met any, you know?
Just never have.
A lot of my guy friends need
an awful lot of help, you know?
Which we will freely
admit, you know?
But not so much the women.
But in answer to that question,
what is it like to be a
best-selling novelist?
I tell a story about my
kids when they were little,
my kids are both grown now.
But my daughter was five or
six, I took her to a bookstore
for the first time for a
book signing I was doing.
We walked into the store and she,
you know, all the people were there
and the lady who ran the store
came over and introduced herself
and asked my daughter, do you know
why all these people are here?
And my daughter said,
yes, I do know.
And she goes, why are they here?
They want my dad to sign their book.
And why do they want your
dad to sign their book?
Because my dad has the
nicest handwriting.
[laughter].
She's been out of college
a few years now,
I think she still believes
that, actually.
When my son was maybe three,
I took him to a bookstore
for the first time -- not
for an event, I just took him
to a bookstore so, you
know, to buy some books.
And my son has always been kind of
like my entrepreneur guy, you know?
Always looking, what's the
next thing, the next big thing?
So we walked into the bookstore
and he saw all of the books and all
of the people reading and his eyes
got huge and, all of a sudden,
my kid started running across the
bookstore at the top of his speed,
screaming at the top of his lungs,
my daddy will sign any book
you've got for two dollars.
[laughter].
So that's what it's like to
be a best-selling novelist.
My handwriting is beautiful
and I charge two dollars
to sign your book.
Because I love this
festival so much,
I have waived my book
signing fee today
and we'll sign your
book free of charge.
Now it's one thing to be a
writer, want to be a writer,
and another thing actually being
a writer who can support yourself.
So back then, I was
writing short stories.
Short stories are great
for young, aspiring writers
because they're short and
you can finish one and sort
of feel good about yourself.
So I did that for about 15 years
and I had to earn a living so I went
on to college and went on to law
school at UVA in Charlottesville
and then spent time
practicing law in DC in the city
for about 10 years -- but writing
the whole time in my off hours,
you know, middle of the
night, early in the morning,
wherever I could find some time.
And people ask, you know, was
it a hard transition moving
from being a lawyer to being
a writer, a fiction writer?
And I said, no, you know,
being a lawyer actually is a great
background for writing fiction.
[laughter].
Because, as a lawyer, you know,
it was like the more I made up,
the more I won, which
is awesome, you know?
So it's actually a way
to write effectively
and to argue persuasively.
When you're a lawyer, you
have the same set of facts.
It's called a trial record,
so it's not like you can --
you're entitled to your own opinion
but not your own facts,
in other words.
That doesn't seem to be the
case these days, actually.
But I'm not going to
talk about that.
But you write in a way that's
persuasive before a judge or a jury
and that's telling a story.
So the transition actually
wasn't all that difficult going
from being a lawyer
to being a writer.
I wrote short stories, screenplays,
eventually moved on to novels.
I saw a statistic the other
day that was astounding to me,
that 70% of Americans don't
really enjoy their work --
and so almost three-quarters
the population.
And the reason, you
know, I hate that is
because we spend so
much time at work.
But people find their
joy and interest
in positive things outside of work.
It could be, you know, a sport
that you like, friends, family,
your church, whatever, we find,
you know, lots of ways to be happy.
But we do spend a lot
of time working
and we should be happy doing that.
And I tell people, you know,
it sounds like a cliche
to follow your dream but it's
actually maybe more complicated
than that.
You have to work hard at
whatever you want to do
but it's worthwhile
taking some time early on,
trying to decide what it is
really that interests you.
And if you take months,
weeks, years,
decades to actually finally find out
what it is and because you're going
to be sending your whole life doing
it, which is a really, really,
really long time, it's
worthwhile taking the time to try
to figure out, what
would bring me joy.
Because look, if you love what
you do -- another cliche --
you never work a day in your life.
Writing is hard.
Any creative endeavor is hard
because you're creating something
that did not exist
before you thought of it.
It's not like really any other job.
You know, you get good at other jobs
by sort of doing the same thing over
and over again and working
out all of the bugs,
working out all of the kinks.
I mean, I wouldn't -- I fly a lot.
I wouldn't want to be on
a plane when the pilot
that day says, you know what?
I've never tried this before,
but today I'm going to go for it.
Or a surgeon on an
operating table --
you know, I've done this procedure
for 30 years with my right hand,
let's see what it feels
like with my left.
But as a writer, every
day is different.
There is no formula.
There is no template for
what you're supposed to do.
You just sit down and
try to think of something
that might be interesting to you.
But if you find a passion in
life, particularly with your work,
treat it as the special moment that
it is because, all of a sudden,
you have this eureka moment of,
this is how I can spend my life.
Passion rarely comes around in life,
particularly with what
you do for a living.
So don't let it pass by -- seize
it, you know, and use it and move
on with your life and
do that sort of thing.
You don't want to look back 50 or
60 years from now and wondering,
you know, maybe I should've decided
and gone down that other path.
It's worthwhile, I think,
to think about these things.
My first novel was Absolute Power.
It was about the president,
a burglar, a cover-up,
the truth coming out
and people said, well,
you were an overnight success.
And I said, yes, I was, it only
took me 6000 nights to get there.
I just wanted to tell a good story.
I had no idea that this book
was going to be successful.
I'd had very little success with my
short stories and my screenplays,
but I've always thought that
if you write with passion,
that passion will kiss the
words that you're writing about
and will lift it up out of the
sludge piles that are sitting
on editors' desks in New York City.
You don't want to write
a trend book.
A trend book is like what's hot,
what's really hot out there.
I can guarantee you, you know,
when Jurassic Park first came out,
every script in every book
pitched to anybody had dinosaurs.
I don't care if it was a romantic
comedy, there was gonna be a,
you know, a Tyrannosaurus
rex right in the middle
of this little tryst going on.
Or when the Da Vinci Code
came out, everybody wanted
to write the code book because that
was hot, or the Harry Potter Series,
everybody wanted to do wizards
and witches and stuff like that.
But if you're not interested in
actually that subject matter,
guess what's going to happen?
You're going to run out of gas.
It could be a quarter of the way
through, half the way through,
and the book's not
going to be that good
because you weren't really
interested in writing it anyway.
You just thought it might sell and
you could sell the movie rights
and then you could, you
know, fax in your resignation
from the job you didn't like --
not a really great
motivation to write a book.
The old adage is, "write
what you know."
I would modify that
a little bit to say,
"write what you would
like to know about."
Then you sort of immerse
yourself in a world
that you really didn't know
before but have been fascinated
by for a long time and
guess what happens?
You spend a lot of
time thinking about it.
You spend a lot of time working
on it and, all of a sudden,
the sentences become better,
the paragraphs become better,
the chapters become
more enthralling,
the story becomes more powerful.
It really does work that way.
It's almost like you're putting
the right fuel inside your car.
Otherwise, if it's just
tracing a trend, you're putting
in stuff that's just not
going to ignite into anything.
Now with the Vega Jane
series, I love fantasy.
How many people love
reading fantasy?
Yeah, it's awesome stuff.
There's a lot of fantasy
going on in DC right now.
[laughter].
But I will not speak of that.
But I hear people say it
a lot, so it must be true.
So about, I guess, seven
or eight years ago, my --
like my mother did years before,
my wife gave me a blank
page book for Christmas.
Do not ever give a writer a
blank paper on a major holiday
because I immediately ran away
to my little cubbyhole
and started writing.
And I wrote this name down on
the first page -- Vega Jane.
I have no idea where
the name came from,
it just sounded really
great and it was in my mind.
And I wanted to write a
fantasy about Vega Jane and,
five years later, it was done.
And it took me about
four-and-a-quarter years
to understand what I wanted to
write about with this person,
what the story was
going to even be about.
But after four-and-a-quarter
years of really thinking about it,
obsessing about it, then I
wrote the entire first book
in about seven or eight months.
And nobody knew I was writing it --
none of my friends, my publisher,
my agent -- no one,
other than my wife.
She read it and really enjoyed
it and she is a tough critic.
I know she's here somewhere.
You know, I won't ask her to stand
up but I can sense your presence.
And when we sent the
book out to publishers,
I was adamant about this point.
I sent the book out under
a pseudonym, a fake name,
because I wanted the book to
be accepted on its merits not
because my name was attached to it.
So I used the name Janus Pope --
Janus is the Roman two-faced god.
I was being very deceitful.
And Pope was just that
Catholic thing, you know?
You never know where names
are going to come from.
So when Scholastic ended up buying
the first book in the series,
The Finisher, the way
the book is written --
the terms, colloquialisms
and all that --
they thought I was from England.
So when I went to Scholastic in
New York and introduced myself
as the author of The Finisher,
they were quite shocked, you know?
Clifford, you know, the Big
Red Dog, he like fainted.
[laughter].
He's in lobby up there.
It's like [thud].
For me, writing that book
was an enormous challenge.
I'd never written that genre
before but it's great in life,
no matter what you do, to
get out of your comfort zone,
you know, to scare yourself.
People say, you know, what
really drives you as a writer?
And I say fear.
Fear drives me as a
writer, you know?
Can I tell another
good story or not?
You know, you have this recurring
nightmare that people are going
to wake up one day
and realize, you know,
you have no idea what
you're doing, you know?
You ever have that recurring
dream when you're in school
and you're back in school and
you showed up naked for a test?
Or you haven't been to class
all year and now you have
to take the exam and
you know nothing
of what's on there, you know?
Psychologically, you know,
there's a lot of stuff that goes
into the interpretive dreams and
they show anxiety in your life,
loss in your life, some type of
nervous situation you're addressing
so you dream about it in that
symbolic way and that's why you --
we all share those dreams because
we share those types of anxieties.
But for me to get out
of my comfort zone
and write this book was
really important as a writer.
I think it made me a
better thriller writer
for having written
this fantasy series.
So the book came out,
hit number one and,
you know, was very well-received.
I used my name when
the book came out --
Scholastic insisted upon that -- I
think it probably did help sales.
But Vega Jane is the lead character.
She's a young girl and, as
I just mentioned before,
she's a very strong,
independent female.
And she lives in a little village
called Wormwood in the middle
of nowhere and you have no idea
in what time period this is set.
And in Wormwood, there's
this place called the Quag
and there's nothing beyond the Quag.
There's no reason to leave
Wormwood and the Quag is filled
with dangerous beasts so you stay
in Wormwood, the little village,
and you'll be fine, perfectly safe.
You don't have to take a chance or
a risk, which is sort of symbolic
of what I was trying to say about
getting out of your comfort zone.
It's almost like in the
universe saying, you know,
we're the only planet out of 87
hundred thousand trillion planets
that might have life on it so
we should just stay where we are
because it will be safe here.
Vega Jane realizes everything
she's been told in life is a lie --
everything -- about Wormwood,
the people that live there,
their history, everything.
So she breaks out of Wormwood and
goes to the Quag, fights her way
through the Quag in the second
novel, The Keeper, and then we come
to The Width of the World.
The Width of the World
title comes from one line
in the epic poem, Beowulf.
I love just the alliterative,
how that rolls off the
tongue, The Width of the World.
And it really talks about the
world as they knew it back then.
This is the breadth and spectrum
of the world in this epic poem.
And in this book, The Width of the
World, that came out in the spring,
she's in a brand-new world.
Unlike a lot of fantasies,
for every book that I wrote,
I had to create a brand-new world
because Vega kept escaping
from places.
So The Finisher was Wormwood.
The Keeper was the Quag.
And now in, The Width
of the World, it was --
she had broken free from the Quag,
was now in this place
that looked more modern.
It would have things that
we would recognize --
buildings and the clothing
people wore
and automobiles and
things like that.
And it seems like a safe place,
it seemed like the
people are very happy.
But Vega Jane soon realizes
that people there are sort
of suffering the worst
form of enslavement
because they don't even know
they're actually enslaved.
So there's no opportunity or
chance of any type of insurrection
because they just feel
so good about everything,
not even knowing the fact
that they're not free.
Now I wrote this series as sort
of -- not for young readers,
not for old readers, not
for in-between readers.
I only know one way to
tell a story, you know?
I bring my A-game.
And just because I was writing
for middle grade readers,
that was a category that sort of
the industry puts on this book,
that meant nothing to me.
All I know is that I was going
to be writing for myself but also
for really smart people out
there who probably read a lot
of fantasy regardless of whether
they're 10 or 110 and were going to,
you know, judge this book
on how good the story was
and how good the writing was
and what it was really about.
So when people say, is it easier
to write for young readers?
I said, it's not easy
to write for any reader.
And so you really have
to bring you're A-game.
And as plot, character,
action, twists and turns --
only really conscious choice
I made was maybe, you know,
word selection here and there.
You know, certain words
that I might use
in an adult book I wouldn't
use in a book like this.
So I'm working on the fourth novel
here and we just got a title for it.
Scholastic said the legal department
said I can't reveal that title --
I hate lawyers, don't you?
I mean -- where do they
get off doing that?
I've got some stuff going on.
They're filming the Christmas
Train movie right now in Vancouver
that will be out over Thanksgiving
weekend on the Hallmark Channel
and they've been sending
me the dailies every day.
Used to -- when you filmed the
old way on just regular film,
you'd have to wait like a
week to see the dailies.
Now it's all on video so they
email me the video so I get
to see all the dailies on my laptop.
It looks really cool, you know?
They're making Vancouver in August
look very Christmasy, which is nice.
And I read an article
the other day that said,
the Hallmark Channel
ratings are through the roof.
They have like tripled
since January.
And the reason being that, you
know, people just want to feel happy
about something and, you know, have
a good ending and just feel good
about themselves -- since January.
[laughter].
I thought about that a lot,
I can't build a connection.
[laughter].
A and B -- it just.
So I would say again,
any writers in this room?
Any aspiring writers in this room?
You know, follow your dream, follow
your passion, follow, you know --
just sit down every day and
realize that what you're working
on would not exist but for you.
It's a very special feeling, a
very important responsibility but,
at the end of the day,
have fun doing it.
Don't make it so serious that
you take all of the joy out of it
because joy, much like pain, can
result in a lot of great stories
that all of us in this room can
enjoy for a long, long time.
Thank you very much, and
I'll take some questions.
[ Applause ]
>> I wanted to ask about the process
of getting a literary agent and how
that worked out for you, David.
>> David Baldacci:
Getting a literary agent --
I knew I needed an agent
so my way of getting lists
of agents was a little unorthodox.
I would go out to -- when I
had heard about a first novel
and hitting really big, I would
go to the bookstore and I'd look
in the acknowledgments and
they always thank their agent.
You know? First, it's the
spouse and then it's the agent.
If it's the agent before the spouse,
I don't think that
marriage is going to last.
But I got a list of agent that way
and I probably committed
all the cardinal sins
of what you're supposed
to do with a query letter
but I wrote a very short query
letter and I had seven agents
and I made copies of my
manuscript, complete manuscript,
and I sent it up to seven different
agents, simultaneous submissions,
they all knew that other
agents were reading it.
And the query letter said, you
know, my name is David Baldacci,
you have no idea who I am.
I'm a lawyer in Washington, DC.
This book is about the president, a
mistress, a cover-up, and a burglar.
And I can guarantee that, if you
read the first page, you won't stop
until you read the last page.
Sincerely, me.
And I did that for a couple reasons.
One, I felt, if I couldn't
be confident
about my material, how could they?
And secondly, I knew most
of them would read it just
to prove me wrong -- so they could
write back and say, you know what?
No. You actually suck.
So I was hoping that one of
them would write back and say,
you know, this has some potential.
Why don't you write something
else, let me see how it goes.
What happened instead was that
all seven agent contacted me back,
all seven wanted to be my agent --
which, trust me, after 15 years of
like no success was astonishing.
So I went up to New York
and interviewed all of them
and picked the agent
that I have still today.
So it was an unorthodox way to
do it but I think, you know,
if you're looking for an
agent, it's an important thing.
It's not just an agent
trying to make you money,
it's a person who can be a counsel
to you, who can be a mentor to you,
who can be an advocate for you
and advise you over your career.
And the one thing my agent told
me, he said, look, this book,
Absolute Power, I can sell it,
probably sell it for a lot of money.
If this is the only book
you have inside of you,
I have no interest
in representing you.
I don't represent writers,
I represent careers.
So that's really what
cemented it for me.
He was the only one
that ever told me that.
And that's why he's
probably my agent still for,
you know, the last 23 years.
>> Hi. So I was wondering,
I'm sure as a writer you have
so many ideas swirling around
in your head constantly.
And I was wondering how you
decide which ones you want
to turn into an actual book?
>> David Baldacci: Great question.
You know, with all the
ideas swirling in your head,
how do you pick the ones you're
actually going to sit down to write?
Again, there's no rhyme or reason.
It really just speaks
to the interest level.
Sometimes I've read an article that
piqued my interest in something,
then I went out and did some
research, talked to some people,
thought about it, and then decided
ultimately I didn't want to do it
because I just wasn't
jazzed enough about it.
If it's a recurring character,
it's sometimes, like, well,
I've got this character
developed, like an Amos Decker
with perfect recall, what
would be a great story for him
that not only would be
an entertaining story
as a stand-alone novel,
but how can I deepen
and enrich his character even more.
It's got to grab your
interest as the writer.
You may be working on this thing
for years, so you don't want to run
out of gas halfway through.
So it's got to be something that
you're really interested in.
Not just interested in, but
you're willing to say, okay,
I'm going to spend the next few
months finding out more about this.
Talking to people.
Going to some of these places.
And I have the energy and
interest level to do that.
And if you carry it
through that far,
then I think that your decision
is probably going to be,
I've got this one, I'm going
to go with it the whole way.
But don't be afraid to
just also cut and say no,
I don't have the fire for it.
And what you don't want to do
is write 200 pages and then,
all of a sudden, I'm done.
It's happened to me.
It's happened to every writer.
You make those mistakes sometimes.
But really is almost
a gut sort of thing.
Am I interested enough in this to
be friends with it for two years.
It's like a relationship.
Are you going to be
there for it or not.
>> Hi. So you said that you
have a background as a lawyer.
I wanted to ask -- you said
specifically being a lawyer is a
great background for
being an author.
I wanted to ask if there are like
specific things in your books
that are inspired by your experience
as a lawyer or like techniques
that come from being a lawyer that
crossover into being an author?
And is it as fun and exciting being
a lawyer as it is being an author?
>> David Baldacci: Absolutely, yeah.
The last question first.
It's a lot more exciting
being a writer than a lawyer.
That's just me.
I appreciated practicing
law for as long as I did.
It made me be a better
person, a better writer,
a better business person.
My publisher, my old publisher,
used to lament the fact, he goes,
you're the only one of my writers
who actually reads the damn
contracts, understands them,
and have changed them, you
know, to benefit writers more.
Which I have done that.
There was a book I wrote
called The Simple Truth.
And that was about a soldier who
had unwittingly been exposed part
of an experiment to build a super
soldier through chemical process.
Didn't know that he'd even been
part of this, it was involuntary.
And during one of these episodes,
he'd actually killed someone.
And he'd been imprisoned for life
for it because no one told anybody
that that's actually what happened.
And the military -- which, you
know, nothing against the military.
My dad was in the military, and I've
written a lot about the military.
But the military sometimes
makes mistakes.
And this was based on an actual
program that actually they had,
the Super Soldier Program,
using PCP to try
to make soldiers super
during the Vietnam War.
And the Army sent him a
letter when he was in prison
like 20 years later apologizing.
Oops, you know, we
kind of messed up.
And that was the first he knew
about it, and the guy went crazy
and escaped from prison and, you
know, he didn't know what to do.
And I had represented,
my firm had represented,
a soldier in circumstances
similar to that.
And after having read, you know,
on the subject, that was something
that really piqued my
interest and I wanted to do it.
As far as sort of attributes
of lawyers and writers,
we share a lot of commonality.
As a lawyer I would work on
big projects, either trials
or acquisitions, corporate
deals, for years.
So I was not daunted by the fact
that it might take me
years to write a book.
That's all I was used
to as a lawyer,
working on projects for years.
So every day -- you
pace yourself every day.
You know, you're not to
get it all done in one day.
And for a lot of aspiring writers,
you get, oh my god, you know,
it's been two months, I
don't have the book done yet
and don't have the movie
sold, and you get frustrated
and impatient and you quit.
Pace yourself.
It's not going to be done in a
day or a month or even a year.
And it's about putting
little pieces together.
You know, with a trial,
it's a big puzzle
and you're putting pieces together.
The sorts of books that I
write, thrillers and mysteries,
it's the same sort of
thing, it is a puzzle
and I'm putting every piece together
and I have to fit them perfectly.
Because if one doesn't
fit perfectly,
the whole puzzle falls
apart, and you're going
to go like, what was that about.
You know, that makes no
sense at all, you know.
So for me, you know, part of
it was cases that I worked on,
cases that I knew about,
but also just the attributes
of what I did every day as
a lawyer made the transition
to being a full-time writer easier.
>> Thank you.
>> Hi. I first heard you speak when
you came six or seven years ago.
>> David Baldacci: Did
I tell the same stories?
I'm sorry if I did.
>> No, it's a different story.
At the Carlisle, Pennsylvania,
Celebrate the Book Festival.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you for that.
That started me volunteering
with the library more and more.
And the question I have, with your
Vega Jane series, which is different
from your other books --
it's very interesting.
My daughter is very upset
that I'm reading her books.
The lexicon that you use in that,
the made-up words, how do you know
when too much is too much
and too little is too little
and enough is just enough?
>> David Baldacci:
That's a great question.
That can speak to the
whole writing a book.
What is too much, what
is too little.
You have to immerse
yourself in that world.
And you have to look
at both as a writer
and as a potential
reader of the book too.
I'm a big reader.
Lots of writers read voraciously.
So you sort of have to be the
creator and also the consumer.
And how would I perceive that
chapter, that set of words,
that character development,
is it too much, too little.
If I were a reader of this book
and somebody else had written it,
would I be satisfied with it.
So for me, I've been
doing this a long time.
And one thing you do learn
over time is that less is best.
And I'm sort of like
Hitchcock, I leave something
to the imagination, you know.
I don't want to write
everything out in
such great detail you have nothing
else to think about as the reader.
When you go to see the movie, you
know, you see a two-hour version
of what a director thinks the story
should be, and you have your soda
and your big popcorn and
all that, and you go away.
You don't really contribute
to the process.
As a reader, you contribute
A book is never finished really
until a reader finishes it for him
or herself, then it's
finished for them.
And they can come away with a
complete different interpretation.
We were talking about
this out in the hall.
A completely different
interpretation
of what the writer
actually intended.
So for the language, it was really,
you know 20 years of having --
or 30 years of having done this,
of knowing that you've
got to pull back.
You know, too much is always
worse than too little.
And if you have too many
words, it dilutes the power
of what you're trying to do.
So for me, I always pull back.
I also pull back with the research.
I know that 90% of the researcher
that I use is never going
to end up in the book.
I'm not writing a treatise.
I'm not writing, you know, a
nonfiction work or textbook.
I'm writing a novel.
So you can integrate -- you know, I
might have done three months' worth
of research for a book
for a sentence here,
a little bit of a paragraph over
here, a line of dialogue over there.
You never want to turn you
research into a flipbook
where you just you have no idea
where to put all this
research you're so proud of,
but you don't want to leave it out.
And you're just like [makes
sound] and you slap it
in the middle of the book.
I called it a flipbook,
because you're the reader
and you're reading it like,
oh my god, what is this?
And you're like flip,
flip, flip, flip, flip.
And you get past all the crappy
research that he just stuck there
and you get back to the story.
So for me, take the
foot off the gas.
One more question.
>> Hi. I would like to ask
what techniques do you use
to develop language,
vocabulary, dialogue,
and terminology in
speculative fiction?
>> David Baldacci: What
kind of what I use?
>> Language, dialogue.
>> David Baldacci: Oh, okay.
It depends on locality, what
part of the world or the country
that I'm in, what sort of
people that I'm talking about.
And if you look at a book
like Wishing You Well,
it was set in the top of a mountain
in 1940 in Southwest Virginia.
I wasn't alive in 1940, but I know
that part of the country really,
really well and the people who
live there really, really well.
I know how they speak.
I know how they act.
I know how they would
respond to certain things.
And that's why it's really important
when you're writing a book,
you can't sit behind your
desk and Wikipedia everything.
Anybody can do that.
You got to get out and go to
the places, talk to people.
Being a great writer equates
to being a great listener.
And listening is a
lost art these days.
I know I'm up here
speaking to all of you.
I would much prefer to
be in the back watching
and listening to all of you.
Because I think being a great
storyteller means that you just have
to be -- have this insatiable
desire to know things.
You want to know things
and more things.
You want to know what
makes people tick.
So really it's just experience.
Every writer writes some
stuff based on experience.
But at the same time,
you have to go out --
if you want to write about a world,
you have to go out and experience
that world as best as you can
and talk and sit and listen
and eavesdrop and overhear the
sorts of people that you're going
to be writing about,
to make it authentic,
make it plausible,
and make it realistic.
Because otherwise, you're just
typing instead of writing.
Thank you very much.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.